I am a voice Alvarez and I run for Big E
global services Europe Middle East
Africa and Latin America and it's been
great to have a very good conversations
appear as good thing and the double
really want mustard on things for me is
the necessity of e importantly doing the
actions we have this big discussion and
then if I can take that two or three
main topics that we have discussed here
the first one is employment an
appointment for 10 people is probably
the most beautiful girl should focus on
second one is a around specific areas of
development like cyber security or near
and against before clearly we need to
fight for having a much more sustainable
world I think that the commitment of
people and the energy you can feel here
as well prolly we should take back to
each one of our jobs and our functions
and our goals make sure that we will
continue to work for a much better
moment any thank you